another bruising day before congress for
secretary of state anthony blinken a
senate panel grilling him for answers
about the botched withdrawal from
afghanistan because so far the biden
administration has refused to say it did
anything wrong republicans not mincing
words
you own this
the biden administration
caused this disaster this was a complete
debacle we had every reason to believe
and to plan for the rapid collapse
of the afghan military and the afghan
government
president biden has described
the evacuation from afghanistan
as an extraordinary success this has to
be the lie of the 21st century and
things got really heated when senator
ted cruz pressed lincoln on whether u.s
officials gave the taliban a list of
names of american citizens during the
chaotic evacuation
did the state department give the
taliban a list or multiple lists of
americans and or afghans that we wanted
out
those reports and the idea that we would
do anything to endanger
our citizens or anyone else at a time
when we were trying to save their lives
is flat out wrong in
limited instances where we were seeking
to get a bus
or a group of people through a
checkpoint
we gave a manifest to the people at the
checkpoint to demonstrate that those
people were expecting roughly how many
names were on the list you gave doesn't
matter because they all dozens hundreds
thousands give us some order of
magnitude this happened in a handful of
situations where dozens so is it your
testimony it wasn't hundreds i want to
understand did you give them thousands
of names no we did not and on and on it
went jesse one of the things senator ron
johnson
said to blinken is that it
there's some frustration that it feels
that the administration is detached from
the situation
so he did an okay job cruz did much
better but the republicans in general
were focused way too much on sound bites
that they can push out to donors and on
social media this hearing needs to be
about establishing a pattern of facts a
timeline and getting direct testimony on
the record when did you know
and what did you know and when did you
know it and then you can present that
evidence to the american people and
that's how you get to the truth and
accountability kabul did not fall in 11
days dana that is a lie
it took months for the afghan army to
desert and surrender the taliban
takeover came after three months biden
was briefed by the intelligence agencies
state department cables went out embassy
cables went out but i knew in july that
the taliban was taking over because he
got on the phone call with the afghan
president said live for me make sure it
looks better on the ground so i get help
politically and then maybe i'll give you
a little more air support so the lies
cost lives and we need to know the facts
so
al qaeda's back in afghanistan
and we have dead marines and we have a
huge technology transfer to the chinese
military
which we're going to have to deal with
in the pacific and now we're importing
all these child brides we're bringing in
thousands of afghan men who married 12
year olds
cruz got into that where are these
people going to live dana in america we
call them child molesters they're not
going to live in any blinkens
neighborhood so what are we going to do
with them so if this was a republican
president you'd already have impeachment
hearings they the democrats go after
these hearings like litigators during a
homicide trial republicans you act like
it's debate club no we want answers we
deserve answers and we're not going to
get it if you just beat around the bush
jessica many times these hearings do
feel performative not productive um
i think in the house side they had three
to five minutes and that senate side
they have seven so there's benefits i
guess to being a senator um but there
was something from senator bob menendez
um in terms of his frustration as the
oversight chairman watch
the execution
of the u.s withdrawal was clearly and
fatally flawed
this committee expects to receive a full
explanation of the administration's
decisions on afghanistan since coming
into office last january there has to be
accountability i want to get your take
on something so
lloyd austin would not testify today as
a secretary of defense they said that
well he's going to be testifying in
front of another committee later this
month there's some frustration from
people who follow this that this is all
just being done in a piecemeal way and
they would like to have a commission
like the 911 commission or something is
that something you think democrats would
be willing to do i actually do think
it's something democrats would be
willing to do i mean bob menendez is a
strong biden supporter this is just like
any democrat this is someone from the
get-go backed by it and wanted to back
biden in 2016 when hillary ended up
being the nominee and his words were as
forceful as ted cruz's words or ron
johnson's words and yesterday we saw it
from key figures in the democratic house
like a karen bass
and i think that it is going to continue
i do think on an optics level it made a
big difference that secretary blinken
was in person today absolutely not that
it was his fault for not going yesterday
the was the rules that you could zoom in
there was even the congressman who was
in his closet
who did it but
you should be there this is a big deal
it will be as leon panetta said it would
be a huge
moment in his time as secretary of state
for better or for worse and i did like
the dynamic better in person it needs to
be treated with respect especially since
we lost
um
american lives uh 13 and 18 wounded um
but it felt like a bipartisan
shellacking to me it felt like yesterday
with longer time limits and i think that
that's something that the biden
administration is prepared for they know
what the polling looks like on this
and they're going to show up and and
they're going to take it katie one of
the things that frustrated some of the
people that are working behind the
scenes
these private groups working with
veterans who are trying to get their
interpreters and their families out was
when anthony blinken said
every one of the people and i guess he
was talking about the americans that are
left behind and the green card holders
has been assigned a caseworker right
case manager and they have a team of
case managers and one of the young women
i talked to said
that she said that can't be true because
if it is true then all these messages
i'm getting are just people who
absolutely can't get anybody to return
their calls at the state department well
the state department has now tried to
kind of take credit for these private
groups and organizations that have been
able to get people out when the
government has failed to do so and when
the secretary of state was asked if the
state department you know didn't allow
certain flights to take off if they were
denying people access to to the airport
the answer from the secretary of state
was no when we know from talking to a
number of people and from sourcing that
they were denying flights taking off
they were denying people coming into the
airport and they were telling people to
come to the airport when they couldn't
get there because the taliban wasn't
letting them through for weeks on end
the bipartisan nature of this i thought
was interesting and based on
the idea that when you listen to each of
them speak today and this happened a lot
yesterday in the house every single
senator and congressman has a story
linked to trying to getting somebody out
of afghanistan and it is you know the
java congressional offices and offices
in the senate to help get people home
but it really is the state department's
job and for the administration up to
this point to keep saying that this was
a successful airlift it was a successful
evacuation when you have senators and
congressmen still getting phone calls
from americans and sivs who are stuck in
afghanistan that really makes it a lot
closer to each of their offices in the
work that they're doing i also wanted to
say one other piece of sound from
senator ted cruz if you guys could pull
that up because brian this is one of the
questions that americans are going to
have
is oh excuse me it's rand paul the um
664 billion dollars uh that's possibly
going to be going to the um to
afghanistan and i'm wondering does that
does that pass through the afghan
government here's senator rand paul
this week you've now released 64 million
dollars in aid to afghanistan
don't we have some prohibition against
giving aid and comfort to the enemy do
we really are we really naive enough to
believe that we're just going to keep
sending charity to afghanistan and
they're not going to interrupt it
i think that's a foolish notion can you
pledge today without equivocation that
the byte administration will not release
any of this money to the taliban
absent the taliban making good on the uh
commitments and expectations of the
international community that i've
outlined uh previously that's correct
maybe we could deduct a fee for the
weapons they took
brian get your thoughts on that or
anything else yeah 64 million is part of
it to 1.2 billion that we promised uh
for international aid it turns out that
18 million afghans depend on the
government to live in their food and
clothing so congratulations taliban
you've got a country to run all right
not just to people to behead you
actually got to do other stuff so they
want some aid and they also say thank
you very much but can we have more so
they want more
i don't see why we'd give them anything
but you go ahead you want more so i want
you to see that the big thing was over
the last few days is it's trump's fault
it was trump's deal we had no choice so
the guy that's professionally and
undoing everything president trump does
and i think joe biden takes great pride
in it everything donald trump does he
undoes when it comes to the taliban deal
well this is ironclad this is the deal
that trump had it's six pages my health
club uh contract is harder to get out of
than this it is as generic as it gets
anyone can get out of this and you
almost went to law school you did go to
syracuse law school you were at the
bottom of your class you could have
handled how to get out of this agreement
and so i texted mike pompeo and i said
to uh what what was the deal what's the
big difference yeah but but he was he
did have an important job he said we
would only have left once all conditions
are met we didn't plan for chaos because
we wouldn't had it we had constant
deterrence we would hit them as soon as
they broke this agreement and uh bharata
the butcher they said to him flat out if
you break any of this you take any of
these provinces i know where you live we
will kill you like we just kid solomani
and he got that that's why he called at
the edge of kabul and said do you want
me to take it or do you want to take it
and mackenzie general mckenzie says why
don't you take it i'll just take the
airport can we just honestly say that's
one of the stupidest responses to the
taliban and there's been a lot then i've
ever heard in my life i could not have
been more frustrated because not one
democrat did what joe lieberman did
which senator lugar did to president
bush what senator hagel did they
questioned war decisions they forgot
about party nobody forgot what party
they were in today on the democratic
side even though menendez did say well
we're going to we're going to find out
about that but there was more kissing
his bot than calling him he called it an
abject failure brian and in that cl in
your health club uh thing there does it
also say we're going to release 5000
taliban soldiers prisoners for a
thousand afghans 5 000 1 000. i think
it's a bad idea ambassador kalazad cut
absolutely a bad idea but that does not
mean you can't break it push it back and
undo it because it's not in america's
interest also trump isn't president
anymore joe biden is president yeah take
responsibility here we are yeah but i
mean it's uh september we're sort of
deciding that